[Musique]
challans vous conter l'histoire les
aventures des aventures nous allons vous
conter l'histoire les aventures de
on avoue
pour une fois dans cette histoire le
grand perdant sera
la paire de chasse
gagnant nous allons vous des re
[Musique]
et d'hubert ne courait pas si vite
vous savez que je suis votre ami en
vérité mon cher thibert le monde est
bien méchant la charité n'existe plus
chacun cherche à tromper l'autre
l'important est d'avoir un véritable ami
vous par exemple 10 mai est ce vrai
renard
absolument je me sens pour vous une
grande affection
[Musique]
j'en ai ma part au renard bien sûr nous
ne sommes nous pas amis mais nous devons
tous partager alors partageons des
mangeons
[Musique]
ce lieu ne me semble pas assez à les cas
mieux vaut l'emporter ailleurs dans un
endroit où nous serons plus tranquille
parfait
comment porter vous donc ces andouilles
regardez les deux bouts qui traînent
dans la poussière
moi je les porterai autrement et comment
cela
[Musique]
et moi thibert pas si vite
tibère pourquoi êtes-vous monté si haut
montée et nous mangerons ensemble et
comment le pourrait elle c'est à vous de
descendre je resterai ici jusqu'à ce que
vous descendiez même s'il faut attendre
sept ans je jure de ne pas quitter cette
paroisse avant que vous n'en dessandier
[Musique]
non mais quel est ce bruit
alors et votre serment
l'avez vous déjà oublié
[Musique]